自己紹介していいですか？
いいですよ。
アバンティーズ、エイジです！
ゴホゴホ
はい
まあ、マシュマロって食べ物が、
まあ、世の中に存在するわけですよ。
はい
知ってます？
関東だともう、
ま、メジャーだからね。
これ、マシュマロ、
マシュマロをね、
今日は、こちらに、
ちょっと、アマゾンで買った、
ガシスリングショットがあるじゃん？
こういう感じになるって、もう、
本気のスリングショットがあるんで、
今日はね、
このスリングショットで、マシュマロを、
ここにセットして、
こんなん、なっちゃうんだ
早かったわ
早かった
あははは
これヤバいなあ
かわいそう
ごめんなさい🙇
しょ、初対面なんすよね。
というわけで、
さっそく、やっていきましょう。
See you next time👍
さっそく、行きます。
死ね！
いくよ？
パン！
うあ！ｘ3
あははははは
ははは
今、食べたでしょ？
1　パン！
あ、いったいｘ3
あ、でもこれ楽しい
パン！
あ、ごめん
殺してやるって今言った？
んん！ｘ3
ははは
パン！
はあ！ｘ2
殺してやるって聞こえるから、もう
パン！
ダメだ、逃げちゃった
こわ！
パン！
あ゛あ゛あ゛！
いったあ！
なんて顔だよ（笑）
ふざけんなよ（笑）
ふざけてない！まじめ！
パン！
ええあ！
ひぎゃああ！
うああ
あがあ！乳首！乳首！乳首！
かあ↑
ああ！
ぐお！
へえ！
あ、おっしい！
えうえ！
おっぷってってって
あ、うまい
っへえあ
ああう
っでえい
ははは
がっつり、ちんこやん
あがあ！
ふふふふ
いたああ！
脱臼したよ！
ああ！
あ！
よし来い！
うおおお！
二人とも、若いなあ（from 2017、4月）